what's your favorite movie oh
I don't know
you don't know no it depends on my mood
well what are your favorite like give me
three movies you really really like that
I really really like yeah I like oh I
love Pam's Labyrinth oh that's a heater
I love that one
um
I like Scarface
okay like that's the type of movie like
I'll just put on like I'm not watching
it but because I watched it so much it
just makes me feel like I'm at home yeah
um
I like zootopia
you know I never seen zootopia that was
like my comfort movie when I was like
running rooms that's a cartoon right
yeah you say when you're renting rooms
what does that mean renting rooms off of
Craigslist
you were renting rooms off Craigslist
yeah
like to live in before I got signed I
didn't know that you didn't know that
yeah oh that's why I would do car wraps
because my crib wasn't nice or whatever
room I was in wasn't nice so you would
be on Craigslist just like room to room
uh-huh damn
was that like a anything sketch ever
happened
yeah so I remember I had found this
place in Northridge
and
um it was a good ass deal it was like
400 for the room too good so it was with
uh a married couple and I remember they
didn't have any kids
they said they didn't have any kids so
when you run a room you go to the
person's house and they interview you
you interview them so she was hella cool
and she kept saying um you can meet my
husband but the husband was was just
never available but I needed a room
right so I was like okay I'm just gonna
move in without meeting the husband but
then as I was moving into the room I
just noticed there was like
like um you know how kids kids put like
like stickers on the wall yeah
it was a whole bunch of like kid stuff
in there and I was like how y'all not
have any kids but this room has been
occupied by a kid before
it it's just the vibe was just really
weird so I was like I feel like if I
move here I'm never gonna leave this
house so I decided not to stay there oh
yeah that's it that's pretty sketch it
was sketch we might have never have
known who you were because they would
have no really for real I just want did
you have you watched Barbarian yet on
HBO Max it's a [ __ ] up movie but it's
it's pretty good you should watch it but
there's like a this guy like keeps like
girls like under his house and it's like
Kiss the Girls
kind of but like the inbred weird
version It's kind of wild but yeah shout
out to Barbarian